This lecture is about some practical
issues that you would have to address
in evaluation of text retrieval
systems.
In this lecture we will continue the
discussion of evaluation we'll cover
some practical issues that you have to
solve in actual evaluation of text
retrieval systems.
So,
In order to create the test collection,
we have to create a set of queries, a
set of documents and a set of relevance
judgments.
It turns out that each is actually
challenging to create.
First, the documents and queries must
be representative.
They must represent the real queries,
and real documents that the users handle,
and we also have to use many queries
and many documents in order to avoid
biased conclusions.
For the matching of relevant documents,
with the queries we also need to ensure
that there exists a lot of relevant
documents for each query.
If a query has only one, let's say
rather than the document in the
collection, then you know it's not very
informative to compare different
methods using such a query, because
there's not that much room for us to
see difference, so ideally there should
be more relevant documents in the
collection, but yet the queries also
should represent the real queries that
we care about.
In terms of relevance judgments, the
challenge is to ensure complete
judgments of all the documents for all
the queries, yet minimizing human
effort because we have to use human
labor to label these documents, it's
very labor intensive and as a result
it's impossible to actually label all
the documents for all the queries,
especially considering a giant dataset
like the web.
So this is actually a major challenge.
It's a very difficult challenge. For
measures,
It's also challenging because we want
the measures that would accurately
reflect the perceived utility of users.
We have to consider carefully what the
users care about.
And then design measures to measure
that.
If your measure is not measuring the
right thing, then your conclusion would
be misled.
So it's very important.
So, we're going to talk about a couple
of issues here.
One is a statistical significance test
and this also is the reason why we have
to use a lot of queries.
And the question here is how sure can
you be that observed difference that doesn't
simply result from the particular
queries you choose, so here are some
sample results of average position for
system A and system B in two different
experiments.
And you can see in the bottom we have
mean average precision.
So the mean if you look at the mean
average precision.
The mean average precisions are exactly
the same in both experiments.
So you can see this is 0.2.
This is 0.4 for system B and again here,
It's also 0.2 and 0.4, so
they are identical.
Yet if you look at the these exact average
precisions for different queries. If you
look at these numbers in detail,
You will realize that, in one case you
would feel that you can trust the
conclusion here given by the average.
In another case, in the other case, you
will feel that well, I'm not sure.
So why don't you take a look at all
these numbers
for a moment?
Pause the video.
So if you look at the average, the mean
average precision, we can easily say
that, well, system B is better, right?
So it's afterwards 0.4 and then this is
twice as much as 0.2, so that's
a better performance.
But if you look at these
two experiments. Look at the detail
results,
You will see that would be more
confident to say that in the case
one in experiment one.
In this case, because these numbers
seem to be consistently better for
system B .
Whereas in experiment 2,
We're not sure because looking at some
results like this.
Actually System A is better and this is another
case.
System A is better.
But yet if we look at the only average,
System B is better.
So,
What do you think?
You know how reliable
Is our conclusion, if we only look at
the average?
Now, in this case, intuitively we feel
experiment one
is more reliable.
But how can we quantitatively answer
this question?
And, This is why we need to do
statistical significance test.
So the idea of statistical significance
test is basically to assess the variance
across these different queries.
If there is a
A big variance that means the results
could fluctuate a lot according to
different queries.
Then we should believe that unless you
have used a lot of queries, the results
might change if we use another set of
queries.
Right, so this is not. So,
If you have see high variance then it's
not very reliable.
So let's look at these
results again in the second case,
right?
So here we show two different ways to
compare them.
One is signed test where we just look
at the sign. If system B is better than
system A, we have a plus sign when
System  A is better,
we have a minus sign, etc.
Using this case,
If you see this, well, there are seven cases.
We actually have 4 cases where system B
is better, but 3 cases System A is
better.
You intuitively.
This is almost like a random result,
right?
So if you just take a random sample of
two to flip 7 coins, and if you use
plus to denote the head and then minus
to denote the tail, and that could easily be the
results of just randomly flipping
these 7 coins.
So the fact that the average is larger
doesn't tell us anything and we can
reliably conclude that, and this can be
quantitatively measured by a P value and
that basically,
means the probability that this result
is infected from random fluctuation.
In this case probability is 1.
It means it surely is random
fluctuation.
Now in Wilcoxon test, the nonparametric
test and we would be not only looking
at the science will be also looking at
the magnitude of the difference, but we
can draw a similar conclusion where you
say it's very likely to be from random.
So to illustrate this, let's think
about the
such a distribution and this is called
the null distribution.
We assume that the mean is 0 here.
This say we start with the
assumption that there's no difference
between the two systems.
But we assume that because of random
fluctuations depending on the queries.
We might observe a difference, so the
actual difference might be on the left
side here or on the right side here,
right, so?
And this curve kind of shows the
probability that we will actually
observe values that are deviating from
zero here.
Now, so if we look at this picture, then we
see that.
If a difference is observed here,
then
the chance is very high that this is in
fact a random observation, right?
We can define a region of you know likely
observation because of random
fluctuation, and this is 95% of all the
outcomes and in this interval then the
observed values may still be from
random fluctuation.
But if you observe a value in this
region or a difference on this side,
then the difference is unlikely from
random fluctuation, right?
So there's a very small probability
that you will observe such a difference
just because of random fluctuation.
So in that case we can then conclude
the difference must be real.
So, System B is indeed better.
So this is the idea of statistical
significance test. The takeaway message
here is that you have to use many
queries to avoid jumping into a
conclusion, as in this case to say
System B is better.
There are many different ways of doing
this statistical significance test.
So, now let's talk about the other
problem of making judgments.
And as we said earlier, it's very hard
to judge all the documents completely
unless it's a very small data set.
So the question is if we can afford
judging all the documents in the
collection, which is subset, should we
judge?
And the solution here is pulling and
this is a strategy that has been used
in many cases to solve this problem.
So the idea of pulling is the
following.
We would first choose a diverse set of
ranking methods.
These are text retrieval systems.
And we hope these methods can help us
nominate likely relevant documents.
So the goal is to figure out the
relevant documents we want to make
judgments on relevant documents, because
those are the most useful documents
from users perspective.
So then we're going to have each to
return top K documents.
The "K" can vary from systems right?
But the point is to ask them to suggest
the most likely relevant documents.
And then we simply combine all these
top K sets to form a pool
of documents for human assessors, to
judge.
So imagine you have many systems, each
will return K documents, will take the
top K documents and we formed the
union.
Now, of course there are many documents
that are duplicated bcause many systems
might have retrieved the same relevamnt
documents.
So there will be some duplicate
documents and there are also unique
documents that are only returned by one
system and so the idea of having
diverse set of ranking methods is to
ensure the pool is broad and can
include as many possible relevant
documents as possible.
And then the users would.
Human assistance would make a
completely judgment on this data set
this pool.
And the other unjudged
documents are usually just assumed
to be non relevant.
Now if the pool is large enough, this
assumption is OK.
But the if the pool is not very large,
this actually has to be
reconsidered and we might use other
strategies to deal with them, and there
are indeed other methods to handle such
cases, and such a strategy is generally
ok for comparing systems that
contributed to the pool.
That means if you participated in
contributing to the pool, then it's
unlikely that it will penalize your
system because the top ranked documents
have all been judged.
However, this is problematic for
evaluating a new system that may have
not contributed to the pool.
In this case, a new system might be
penalized because it might have
nominated some relevant documents that
have not been judged, so those
documents might be assumed to be
non relevant.
That's unfair.
So to summarize, the whole part of text
retrieval evaluation, it's extremely
important because the problem is
empirically defined problem.
If we don't rely on users, there's no
way to tell whether one method works
better. If we have inappropriate
experiment design, we might misguide
our research or applications and we
might just draw wrong conclusions.
And we have seen this in some of our
discussion, so make sure to get it
right for your research or application.
The main methodology is Cranfield
evaluation methodology and this is
still the main paradigm used in all
kinds of empirical evaluation tasks,
not just the search engine evaluation.
MAP and nDCG are the two main measures
that should definitely know about and they
are appropriate for comparing ranking
algorithms.
You will see them often in research
papers.
Proceeding at the 10 documents is
easier to interpret from the user's
perspective, so that's also often
useful.
What's not covered is
Some other evaluation strategy like A-B Test
where the system would mix 2, the
results of two methods randomly and
then will show the mixed results to
users.
Of course the users don't see and which
result is from which method the users
would judge those results or click on
those documents in search engine
application.
In this case then the search engine can
keep track of the, clicked documents
and see if one method has contributed
more.
through the clicked documents, if the
user tends to click on one, the results
from one method, then it's just that the
method may may be better, so this is
the leverage the real users of a search
engine to do evaluation.
It's called A-B Test, and it's a
strategy that's often used by the modern
search engines.
Commercial search engines.
Another way to evaluate IR or Text
retrieval is user studies, and we
haven't covered that.
I've put some references here that you
can look at if you want to know more
about that.
So there are three additional readings
here.
These are three mini books about
evaluation and they all excellent in
covering a broad review of information
retrieval, evaluation, and discovered
some of the things that we discussed.
But they also have a lot of others to
offer.